what's going on everybody this is
talking ferns and I am here with a very
special guest tonight this is a man
whose channel I have been a fan of for
quite some time now someone I've been
wanting to record with since the very
beginning this man is a staple a legend
in the game of Thrones community tonight
I present to you the artist formerly
known as Don Willie I am here with a
dawn of Ice and Fire
Joe and will go with everybody this is
Don Willie and yeah I am so glad to be
here on your channel good sir again and
to be discussing the flat leak breaking
things down building it back up see if
it all makes sense and also asking the
pointed questions that need to be asked
of season 7 yes sir I am very happy to
have you on tonight Don we've been
talking messaging each other back and
forth for a while now trying to figure
out when we could record something and
we decided tonight we're going to talk
about this plot leak and try to pick it
apart see what's real what's not what
makes sense what sounds ridiculous and
things like that so we're just pretty
much going to go through it episode by
episode and see what we can come up with
okay Don episode 1 it says the White
Walkers are marching south on the wall
bran crosses the wall back into Westeros
and meets with Dolores Edie the new Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch Sansa and
Jon have an argument about what to do
with the northern houses who betrayed
them by fighting with the Bolton's
Shawn's and Lyanna Mormont wants to give
their lands to loyal supporters but John
refuses to hold the Karstark a number of
children responsible John does it his
way and basically tells the others to
deal with it because he's not going to
rule the north the way it's always been
at the end of the episode Daenerys and
company arrive at Dragonstone Stannis
his old seat in an island near King's
Landing she goes into the old war room
with the table map of Westeros and turns
to Tyrion it says shall we begin so dawn
what do you think about this first
episode alright so you know it sounds
legit for what we know of how they kind
of structure things and I think it could
be pretty interesting if that's the
route that they actually decide to go
with it I mean we did hear about there
being a high stakes scene that's
supposed to be from some more than
houses and a lot of people have been
speculating that this high stake scene
could be possibly people trying to
kidnap the umber and Karstark children
and you know possibly hold them for
ransom or if it's not holding for ransom
that it's a you know this is definitely
some sort of act of vengeance for what
happened during the Battle of the
bastards and you know and other
atrocities that may have been committed
while Roose Bolton and Ramsay Bolton
randon north um it's interesting to
think that John is kind of falling into
some of the same traps that Ned probably
would have yes because yeah the whole
thing about well yeah I'm not going to
hold the kids responsible for what their
fathers did is definitely a Ned Stark
move and and look I hate to say but I
mean like that's how Starks one of
getting their asses killed absolutely
right man and we know John already has
been trying to rule his own pipe away to
like at Castle black with letting the
wildlings come through yeah and you know
for the most part that doesn't seem like
the greatest thing that you can possibly
do I mean look let's think about it
right you know they talk about how
wildlings and the people from the Seven
Kingdoms and especially the Knights
Knights watch have been killing each
other for thousands of years thousands
now for us living right now I don't
think that we can think of a particular
conflict on this planet
from our personal perspectives that have
been going on for thousands of years
that is that is like how do you
reconcile with someone who's been your
enemy for you know longer than you can
actually possibly imagine absolutely
right so yeah I mean John is taking a
big risk here you know again this isn't
going I think this is kind of sorry do
you think this is going to upset like
assuming this is true do you think this
is going to upset a lot of John's other
supporters besides like Shawn's that
having a problem with it do you see some
other northern houses have an issue with
this um I doubt it because of the fact
that they actually proclaimed him as
king in the north
but it was I could see here's the thing
right it's hard to say because yeah we
hear about how these northern houses are
supposed to be so loyal from Sansa but
yet at the same point they didn't show
up for the Battle of the bastards and
yes they're trying to prove themselves
to John but John also has to prove
himself to the rest of them you don't
just get to be king in perpetuity just
because they proclaim you king today you
know they could always repel against you
in and overthrow you and especially for
the fact that John is a bastard you know
it's good you're going to have people
who are going to question him whether or
not they're going to be resentful and
and possibly plot against them
that's a totally different story but um
I could I could see maybe a couple of
families who might be thinking this is
their opportunity to you know get
something out of John Snow uh you know
then being upset at him protecting the
children of the Karstarks and the
numbers
yeah I could see some people have an
issue with that for sure because we've
heard for so long the North remembers
the North remembers but when the Starks
who are you know a big key part of the
North you know one of the most important
families of the North when they were in
their most you know dire situation the
north were they're nowhere to be found
they sided with they sided with Ramsey
you know some of these big houses that
have always been stark supporters yeah
and you know for those of you out there
who may not actually read the books you
know the manderlys which we only get a
very small glimpse of who's supposed to
be Wyman manually in season six even
though I think I heard that they gave
them a different name but the point is
like the manderlys of white Harbor are
supposed to be like 100 percent the most
loyal house and you know it kind of
flips back and forth between them and
the umbers so for the man who leaves not
to show up you know I'm not sure where
you know D indeed aside it is like a
water decided to do that but for the
fact that you have you know two of the
bigger houses one the Karstarks who are
actually start relatives and then you
know arguably the most loyal supporters
being numbers turning on the Starks and
then all the rest of the house is not
even coming to help them except for the
more months and um yeah except for the
month something other than more months
who did they get you know I don't think
they really got anybody else that they
showed us in a show because we know the
Glovers weren't there the umbers weren't
there
the Karstarks weren't there the we heard
the umbers in the course starts with
editing we just went to wrong side oh
yeah that's what I mean like they
weren't there for the Starks the only
big house in the North I think was the
Mormont sand
only had 62 people yeah correct you know
would remember every every one man who
Bear Island fights with the strength of
10 million Landers so you know yes sir
they say man but uh yeah I mean look
like I was saying before I think they
could possibly be resentful even though
they didn't show up for the Starks but
at the same point you know they made him
the king so they kind of got to go with
what he says
Sansa being salty I mean I wasn't I'm
not sure if it was you I think it was
you that was saying that um that Sanford
didn't didn't have a salty look on her
face at the end of season six but I'm
gonna have to disagree with you and I
have evidence okay because what I saw
from my perspective she was smiling at
John and her face only changed when she
saw a little finger lurking in the
background with that same face he always
has when we know he's up to something
and getting ready to plot against
somebody that that was the only time I
saw her face change when she saw the
look on little fingers things right but
you know if you go and actually watch
behind the scenes for season six
especially for that particular episode
she Davos Seaworth getting acted to
place Davos and I believe either Daniel
Dave all three of them said that Sansa
was not happy at the end of season six
and the little finger look was the thing
that made her unhappy not because she
was unhappy for John but it was one of
those things where remember Littlefinger
told her like look you are the true one
daughter of Ned and Catelyn Stark and
he's a motherless bastard from the south
do you really you know what do you
following him and the look on my face is
kind of like oh god damn it you're right
and I hate the fact that you're right
right now yeah the only thing I have to
say about that is when those actors say
things like that in off season I kind of
feel like they're saying that just to
hype it up because I don't think legally
they would want to they could spoil
something like that like a future of
motivation of two big characters
especially against the new king I don't
know why they would let us know that I
mean well that the thing is I don't
think that she would be plotting with
Petyr Baelish to overthrow John right um
but I think it's just more of her being
discontent and sophie Turner as said in
another interview
you know after season six that you know
she not only she not happy but there is
going to be some points of contention
between her and John for Season seven
yes I heard that too and I just don't
feel like if that was true that they
could reveal something like that but
that's just my opinion I mean we'll see
what happens I mean look look at what
the fan in the in the black week yeah
you're right that's it says uh she's
questioning John's actions in the very
first episode if this is true then you
are absolutely right sir but I just did
not see it that way but I could be wrong
you know I could be wrong I mean we we
shall see in a few months yes sir
there's something I want to ask you real
quick about this first episode do you
think this will be something little
single Littlefinger will use like when
John leaves do you think this is when
Littlefinger is going to pull Santa to
the side and say look what he is doing
he's given these houses back to these
traitors do you think he's going to use
that against John when he leaves uh no I
think he I think he is going to depart
peaceably and not only that I think he
is going to kind of stop though the bug
and fans of here like hey look the
Knights of the Vale came
you know they came in my at my command
uh look when you're ready to really you
know execute my plan come and meet me in
the Vale yeah I could see that I could
see some songs of leavin I don't think
she's going to stay at Winterfell for
the entire season I could see her
leaving for sure mm-hmm what do you
think about bran when he returns is he
going to have any issue with John being
king I don't think your brand is going
to have an issue with John being king
but I don't see here's the thing because
since since we don't know how long it's
going to be from the end of season six
to the beginning of season seven like if
it's been months that I'm pretty sure
the nice watch would have heard about
John becoming King and North if it's
like you know a couple of days or
something like they may not have
bothered to tell the nice watch yet so
when brand gets to the wall he may or
may not know because I anacs watch may
or may not know but I let's assume that
they do know um bran
wouldn't have an issue with it because
who else is there right right yeah John
is the one who actually fought for the
north to get it back then you got to
give it to him I agree I said that in
one of my previous videos I don't think
bran is going to have a problem with
this at all and depending on how it is
that he is able to interpret what he saw
at the Tower of joy he would be 100%
okay with it and in fact he like you
know really John as the king of all
Westeros exactly it's absolutely right
yeah so we're just gonna have to see you
know like what information have they
given brand by the time he gets back to
the wall what information have they
given the Nights Watch by the time
bran makes it there because if it's like
the
same damage on becomes king then the
nice wife's probably probably isn't
going to know about it if it's a few
months later which it really shouldn't
be because brand was women with wooden
one mile of the wall that's where that
weirwood tree is supposed to be is
supposed to be within about a mile of
the wall yeah I want to ask you
something about that I said the same
thing I thought he was at the weirwood
tree where the Nights Watch take their
vows yeah I mean because people told me
that he's actually at the weirwood tree
by the fist of the first men first all
of what we would tree by the fist of the
first men that's what I want to know
because I'd completely disagreed I've
said in several videos that he is right
outside the wall yeah I mean when he
looked first off when benjin drops him
off you can see the wall yeah he looks
right at it and it's very close right
and benjin and excellent benzene cells
and hey look I'm glad you over here you
finish doing what you got to do and then
head for the wall I can't go with you
because I'm dead you got to look at it
like this too if he dropped them off at
the fist of the first men how the hell
was she going to get him through the
wall from that good at distance she no
longer has that like will wheelbarrow
thing right so I mean unless mirror is
all of a sudden going to become you know
the Terminator or something like that
there's no way that she was going to get
him from the fist of the first men to
the wall there's no way in hell the
night king and his army would hunt their
asses down before she could even make it
a few miles I mean brand he's a piece of
grown man now she can't carry him that
far right I mean within the crazy thing
about it is you know as like I had well
benjin you dropped him off at the tree
which is a mile away from the wall a
mile away like because I don't I don't
know about you but like for my job I
actually have to do a lot of walking
luckily I don't have to walk miles but
if I had to walk all you know a mile
with my life in danger
oh man that's going to be the longest
mile ever yeah not to mention it's
freezing cold yeah so you know I'm not
sure why Benji didn't just escort them
to the wall say hey look bran you got a
couple of more things you need to learn
go touch the tree I'll be here standing
guard and then once you're done I'm
taking you to the wall sorry I can't go
with you but you know if we actually
they're safe and then be out yeah I
think that may be one of the reasons why
brand was dropped off there I think in
the very first episode we may see him go
into the weirwood net again yeah and you
know what that uh that's going to feed
into something that I'm going to talk
about a little later on as far as the
wayward stuff and flashbacks but uh okay
cool so overall this first episode does
it sound pretty on par with where the
story is going I think it does yeah I
mean there's nothing too outrageous in
terms of you know Justin Townes love
like plot or you know any kind of
deviations or stuff as it seems
implausible so yeah you know maybe those
people yeah this seemed pretty basic so
far let's move on to the second episode
and see see what that sounded like all
right all right guys I'm going to end
this video right here for now we
recorded over two hours of audio for
this public discussion and I wasn't sure
how many of you would like to listen to
a video that was over two hours long so
I took a poll on Twitter and the
majority of you that did vote wanted me
to break this video down into several
parts so I'm going to end the discussion
here and tomorrow I will release part
two of this plot like discussion video
with the dawn of Ice and Fire and me and
most of you have heard me break down his
plot leaked before so I was very excited
to be able to get another game of
Thrones YouTube or on this channel to
discuss these things with and get a
different perspective about what may or
may not take place so hopefully you guys
enjoyed
and if you did please give this video a
thumbs up I always appreciate that and
go over to a dawn of ice and fire
scandal and check out some of his
content
I always appreciate those of you that
subscribed to his channel dawn actually
told me that the last time I gave him a
shout-out in the video he got almost 200
new subscribers so I would love to see
that number go over 2000 total
subscribers because of you guys but
thank you guys for stopping by listening
to the conversation comment below and
give me your thoughts on some of this
stuff I'm curious to know what you think
about some of these things we discussed
and as always I appreciate the support
come back tomorrow for part 2 I will see
you guys in the comment section bye